what's going on everyone axle beats here
for anime uproar one piece has always
been filled with iconic powerful groups
of characters that the entire balance of
the world seems to be shifted around we
have the Admirals the yonko the
Supernova and the topic of today's video
the seven Warlords of the sea if you're
enjoying our one piece content and you
want to see more remember to leave a
like on this video as well as commenting
to let us know which topics you'd like
to see us cover in the future and don't
forget to subscribe so you can keep up
to date on those videos as we do release
them and as always there will be
spoilers ahead so please proceed with
caution you have been warned the
Warlords are of course a group of hired
Pirates Who agree to work with the world
government in exchange for amnesty
basically as long as they come when the
world government calls for them they
have the right to do anything they want
and while this might seem like a pretty
insane idea it actually comes from our
own real world history of privateer
Pirates essentially governments would
hire Pirates back in the day to attack
Merchant ships and Village of rival
Nations which is a bit of a moral gray
area and just like we might have
questions about that sort of thing
characters like Admiral fujitora and
smoker both oppose the warlord system in
the world of One Piece as well with
fujitora even leading to the dissipation
of the warlord system in its entirety
however their impact has already been
felt by the world at this point firstly
Nations like alabasta and dressrosa
where Warlords crocodile and doflamingo
ran rampant are obviously greatly
affected by the Blind Eye that the
government turned towards them but then
you have things like the pacifistas
which were created in Kuma's image or
the more modern variants the seraphim
which seemed to be the culmination of
the world government's experimentations
on Kuma and other characters like King
and all of these seraphims seem to take
the form of younger versions of the
Warlords and will no doubt be used to
stop anyone who stands against the world
government so far we've seen s Hawk s
bear as snake and S shark but that lead
gives the question of who else we're
going to see the original Seven Warlords
all had an animal themed to them and
those seem to be the ones that are being
first produced into seraphim but of
course these seven Warlords of the sea
aren't only seven people we also have
four Replacements over the years and one
pirate who was asked to be a warlord but
turned it down so are all of these
Pirates also on the table because if so
we could be in for some crazy
developments in the future that said
because of the seraphim there have
obviously been eyes drawn back to the
warlord and based on the ones we've seen
having very similar abilities to the
Warlords they're based on we wanted to
take a moment to look back on all of the
Warlords their stories and their
abilities to give us an idea of what is
to come because while many of the
Warlords might not have aged amazingly
well throughout the series I'm looking
at you Moria as a unit and in
combination with all these seraphim
abilities they would be a truly
terrifying Force let's start things off
with the original Seven animal inspired
Warlords the first warlord that we come
across in the story is arguably one of
the most threatening in the series
Dracula Hawkeye mihok is the strongest
swordsman in the world and is currently
the highest known living bounty on any
character who is not a yonko that being
3 billion 590 million his design has the
name Dracula might suggest is very
reminiscent to a Gothic vampire mixed
with a bit of a Renaissance era
swordsman Vibe which let's be real is
one of the coolest things that Oda has
ever come up with it's just very clean
very imposing and gets the idea of his
character across right away bihawk for
the most part is a stoic character
rarely showing emotions and always
carrying that air of superiority with
him that said in situations where he
crosses paths with someone that he
actually respects or who he takes an
interest in he does seem to loosen up
quite a bit specifically we've seen this
with Shanks Zorro Luffy crocodile and
checks notes lightning mcgai one of
these things is not like the other as a
whole though mihawk prefers isolation he
makes his home in the essentially empty
muggy Kingdom as a means of keeping
distance from others that said we see
him allowing Zoro to stay with him and
train we see Corona becoming a travel
partner and we see him visiting Shanks
very early on in the story so while he
might prefer to be alone he obviously
isn't as cold and standoffish as he
might first appear speaking of Shanks
Seahawk was shanks's right level up
until Shanks lost his arm to the Sea
King when saving Luffy and at that point
it was decided the Rivalry was no longer
fair and mihawk lost interest in the
Rivalry altogether they did however
remain unfairly good terms going forward
as mihawk seems to genuinely respect
Shanks in fact in Marine Ford he even
murmurs an apology to Shanks when he
says he's going all out against Luffy
and leaves the battle when Shanks
arrives saying that battling Shanks
would be beyond the scope of his
agreement with the world government and
take note of that battling Whitebeard
was within the scope battling Shanks is
out of the scope now that's all good and
Grand but what about with the people
mihawk doesn't like while normally calm
and collected nihawk also has a bit of a
playful sadistic side and often acts on
his whims our first time learning about
him we have Don Krieg attacking him on
the grand line and then mihawk
destroying his Fleet and following the
survivors back to the east blue just to
cut up their ship when he reached them
all just because he was born Lord he
didn't even consider Krieg a threat he
was just letting off steam but let's
talk about mihawk's actual abilities one
of the first things we see in the series
is Zorro taking on mihawk only for its
greatest efforts to be stopped by what
is essentially a pocket knife
immediately showing an insurmountable
Gap in their abilities in terms of power
we've seen him slicing through ships and
massive icebergs from a long distance
and when Marine Ford comes around he's
also shown to be fast enough to keep up
with Luffy's second gear with ease not
to mention his reaction speed being
quick enough to deflect bullets and
redirect them with his sword and all of
this without ever seeing him really put
in any effort at all the dude is serious
business and then you have his hockey of
which mihawk is skilled in both
observation and Armament however we
haven't seen any indication of
conqueror's hockey from him while his
Armament is likely top tier what mihawk
is really known for is his observation
hockey with eyesight that is able to
keep track of things moving at great
speed which allows him to act with great
Precision earning him the epithet
Hawkeye and speaking of which his eyes
do resemble that of a hawk and there
might be more to that revealed in the
future finally we should talk about his
weapon yoru yoru is one of the 12
Supreme blades and is a massive curved
Black Blade with a cross-leg guard it is
devastatingly powerful however he only
uses it against people who have earned
his respect for others he always has his
small knife inside his pendant which
despite its size can be combined with
his Mastery of swordsmanship to remain a
deadly threat but what does this all
mean for the s-hoc seraphim abilities
well firstly all seraphim are likely
extremely durable and seem to be
upgraded versions of the original
pacifistas complete with their
laser-based abilities which are similar
to The pika pika Nomi the bodies of the
seraphim seem to be artificial lunarians
so we likely have a similar situation to
King's Flames being linked to his
durability s-hawk specifically though is
likely among the fastest models of the
seraphim and uses a sword in combat the
interesting question here is what kind
of Sword does he use is it just a
knockoff yoru with an average blade or
was he supplied with another Supreme
grade sword if the world government does
have access to other Supreme grade
swords this is probably where I would
want to put it if I was them to date
we've only seen four of the 12 Supreme
grades those being yoru shodak Tatsu
murokumulgiri and Ace and I'm sure we're
going to see a few more within the world
government itself and maybe in the
Revolutionary army or among the Giants
on lbath but it would be very
interesting to see one of the seraphim
holding a supreme grave weapon as well
s-hoc will also likely have improved
observation abilities which might allow
him to find enemies more easily or maybe
allow him to fight in less visible
conditions like fog notably s hock like
the other seraphim also has a tube full
of liquid on his right arm that said we
still don't know what this is it could
enable other abilities or it could be
some kind of fuel supply we'll have to
wait and see but for now let's move on
to Jean Bay Jean Bay of course grew up
in the orphanage which became the
Fishman District along with our long and
Fisher tiger and at a very early age he
earned his black belt in Fishman karate
showing himself to be a prodigy almost
immediately as he Grew Older he would
become a soldier in Neptune's Army
however he would eventually resign to
join Fisher Tiger's son Pirates while in
the sun Pirates jinbei would earn a name
for himself and after Fisher Tiger's
death he even racked up a bounty of 250
million ultimately leading to the world
government offering him a position as
warlord which Gene Bay would accept in
hopes of building a better future
between Fishman and Humanity hoping to
live a life which would work towards the
dreams of Queen otohime and Fisher tiger
that said we don't really get to see
jinbei working for the world government
as our first interaction with him is an
impel down where he shared a cell with
Ace because he
to go to war with Whitebeard since then
though we've had a much more fleshed out
look at Gene Bay starting with his
position in big mom's crew and working
towards becoming a straw hat he has
always been demonstrated to be
incredibly powerful in impaled down we
see him taking down huge groups of
guards with a single punch not making
contact with any of them and in Marine
Ford he goes one-on-one beating Moria
with literally no effort while
definitely not on the level of Admirals
he is able to hold his own against
really any opponent even managing to
take similar attacks to the one that
killed Ace and continuing on fairly well
later on Fishman Islands we see him
managing to punch watsume up into the
air as well as beating the Toby Ropo
member who's who in a fight in wano so
it's safe to say he's pretty powerful
and considerably durable as well all of
which is Amplified when he's underwater
as he's a Fishman on top of that he is
such a master of fish man karate that
his punches don't need to make contact
with his enemies as just the particles
of water in the air surrounding him
becomes strong long enough to compress
twist and launch back enemies around him
he can even manipulate the water within
people's body or secrete water from
himself like hody Jones did after
overdosing on energy steroids when it
comes to Fishman karate and the
manipulation of water jinbei is just the
expert and then you have to take into
account his Armament hockey which allows
him to do things like fight with Ace for
five days on equal footing despite Ace
being a logia user it was shown to be
durable enough to protect him from Big
mom's Cognac and from who's whose
rokushiki abilities and of course jinbei
is also a talented observation user as a
whole he's just an extremely
well-rounded fighter that while probably
not top tier he's gonna do okay no
matter who he's against he might not win
every fight but he'll probably survive
no matter who the opponent is after wano
jinbe's Bounty shoots up to 1.1 billion
as a result of him being a former
warlord being instrumental in the
founding of the sun Pirates having ties
to ryugu Kingdom and being a former
Powerhouse member of the big mom crew as
well as now being on another yonko's
crew in the straw hats 1.1 billion puts
him in the top 20 known pirate Bounties
in the series dead or alive and is a
testament to how influential and
Powerful this character really is but
aside from his just pure battle
abilities jinbei is also a masterful
Helmsman who can understand and
manipulate the water around the sunny to
allow his crew to battle or to escape or
to fight regardless of the situation
they find themselves in we even see him
traveling through a massive wave while
being chased by big mom he can also
communicate with animals on some level
although it is specifically with sea
creatures interestingly this is supposed
to be only for merfolk but jinbei is
capable of doing it as well most notably
he does this to summon a massive pod of
whale sharks to help escape the combout
as Luffy and the prisoners are leading
Intel down finally jinbei is obviously
where the S shark seraphim comes from it
appears like a younger jinbei with
lunarian feet pictures but where it gets
interesting is that s-shark seems to
have an artificial version of Senor
Pink's swim swim fruit allowing him to
swim through solid surfaces and to use
Fishman karate with the ground that he
liquefies this is notable for so many
things firstly if s shark has a devil
fruit he can't swim in water so he can't
get the normal benefits that a Fishman
would have in water but he instead
replaces those with on land effects or
at least Inland effects second it means
that the world government managed to
make another successful artificial devil
fruit more specifically this is a fruit
that is perfect for jinbei and not one
that the world government should have
access to directly as I said the
original swim swim fruit user is Senor
pink and while Dopey is a warlord this
implies that the government was able to
access not only the warlord's fruits but
also their Crews meaning the seraphim
have the potential for any devil fruit
belonging to any warlord or their crew
which opens a lot of doors for them if
that's the requirement at all it could
be even more broad than that they might
simply be able to duplicate any fruit in
the encyclopedia however if that was the
case I doubt they would have needed to
perform experiments on kaido to
duplicate his fruit speaking of the
copied version of kaido's fruit is
weaker and a bit faulty compared to the
original so these fruit might not be
optimal either it's probably safe to say
that they don't stack up to the original
versions of these fruit but I would
imagine they are still fairly powerful
either way on to the next warlord with
Bartholomew Kuma Bartholomew the Tyrant
Kuma is a 22 foot tall man who looks
like a missionary carrying a Bible
everywhere he goes as the name Kuma
suggests he is based on a bear and has
several bear-like features but the most
iconic of which are the paw pads on his
hand which come from the devil fruit he
has prior to becoming a warlord Kuma was
the king of the sorbet Kingdom however
he was deposed by his people for being a
tyrant his daughter Bonnie though
suggests that there's more to the story
and that he is simply someone who was
painted as a tyrant by the world
government for standing up against them
while he was King exiled from his Nation
due to the world government's
intervention Kuma would become a pirate
and eventually join the Revolutionary
Army in the opposition to that world
government in doing so he racked up a
bounty of at least
296 million berries however eventually
he would be captured by the Marines and
was originally sentenced to life
imprisonment but vegapunk took an
interest in his unique body and got him
a pardon in exchange for becoming a test
subject through the experiments
performed on him vegapunk would turn him
into the first pacifista a living cyborg
weapon on top of this his clones would
be turned into future models of
pacifistas finally Kuma would lose his
entire sense of self little by little as
he was replaced with more and more
Machinery though there does seem to be
at least a shred of the original Kuma
still inside based on recent chapters so
let's talk Kuma's abilities firstly we
gotta mention his devil fruit the pawpaw
fruit is a paramecia that puts paw pads
on his hands these allow him to
completely deflect anything that comes
into contact with him at a base level
this means he can stop things like
swords punches or cannonballs with his
hands but this is a very unique fruit in
how it allows for some more complex and
imaginative options Kuma can deflect
pockets of air as blasts towards his
enemy or he can condense that air in
front of him into an extremely
pressurized ball that devastates
anything it touches he can Propel things
like pain out of people and make them
into their own separate and tangible
thing and most importantly he can bounce
himself or others to make them move at
incredible speeds to wherever he would
like even to locations that would take
several days of flight to reach and then
we have his pacifista modifications Each
of which give him a boost to his natural
strength speed and durability prior to
being fully converted into a machine
Kuma was strong enough to complete
overwhelmed the entire Straw Hat crew
without any real resistance moving too
fast for them to react not being able to
be damaged by them and just overall
demonstrating what a terrifying force of
power he was he also has lasers very
similar to the pika pika Nomi which are
strong enough to melt steel all of these
extra adaptations seem to be the
Baseline for the seraphim that followed
him except in their cases they also have
the extra lunarian traits and other
devil fruits in place of the pawpaw
fruit however the S bare seraphim based
on Kuma also does seem to have this Papa
fruit as he was used to transport cp0
onto Egghead Island almost
instantaneously so with that said it is
likely the case that if a warlord
already does have a fruit and if an
artificial version of that same fruit is
available in the seraphim modeled after
them will use that same fruit and in
espares case this means that he is able
to offer some astonishing mobility and
defensive abilities for who have ever is
using him at that time next up the snake
princess Boa Hancock aka the pirate
Empress we love boa in this house does
she kick puppies yeah is that a problem
no she's hot unlike the previous
Warlords boa doesn't have any animal
features herself but she does have a pet
snake to fill in that Gap there's a joke
there I'm sure but we're gonna move on
when she was 12 boa and her sisters were
captured by slavers and sold to the
world government it would be held there
for four years until Fisher tiger
liberated them while they were held as
slaves though these sisters were
experience unimaginable Horrors and the
meadow meronomi would be force-fed to
boa because the captors thought it would
be fun now why would a bunch of grown
men feed the love love fruit to a child
I don't know but it is probably related
to her immense hatred for men you can
fill in the blanks yourself the love
love fruit which they fed to her was
hopefully not very useful as a child but
as an adult it is pretty impactful for
her allows her to prey on the lustful or
perverse feelings of others and turn
them into stone we've seen this used on
large groups of people all at once as
they swooned over Hancock but even in
the rare circumstance that someone is
not attracted to her she is able to
combine her fruit with her own body
meaning that if she kicks someone for
example the part of the body that she
kicked will turn to Stone and become
brittle anything turned to stone by
below will remain Stone until she undoes
the effect herself and even if she dies
they won't return to normal otherwise
that said If part of your head was
turned to stone and cracked off I'm not
sure it would be a great idea to turn it
back to normal either way it's a pretty
powerful fruit in her hands which also
leans into her title of snake princess
boa is the ruler of the Kuja an isolated
group of women who live on Amazon Lily
who are fittingly based on femascara and
the Amazon Women of Greek mythology
likely this is also why boa's abilities
seem to be so similar to the Greek
Gorgon Medusa no men are allowed out to
enter Amazon Lily other than Luffy and
Rayleigh and any who do make it on the
island will be turned to stone by boa
it's kind of a perfect defense for her
Island it is also important to note that
while boa was a warlord she literally
never did anything the government wanted
because she hates them so much even the
call to Marine Ford and the threat of
losing her warlord ship was not a good
enough reason to get her to act on their
behalf and it was only because Luffy
needed a ride to impel down that she
agreed to go but even when the war
started she was as much a threat to the
Marines as she was to the Pirates
naturally a few situations would lead
her fruit to being much less effective
firstly if the opponent is blind like
fujitora they are probably less likely
to be hit by the effects not that she is
an extra flirty and seductive when she
wants to actually turn people to Stone
anyways so if she flirts the right way
I'm sure that could still work then we
have people like Luffy who are just
unaware of what sexuality is and they
are entirely unaffected four in cases
like mihawk and smoker where they're
just too serious or too strong-willed
and are able to resist the effects in
general even outside of her fruit though
boa is pretty powerful she's strong
enough to kick through stone or knock
away smoker and she's incredibly agile
and quick I consider her fighting style
to be very similar to sanji's although
he seems to pack a much bigger Punch or
kick in exchange for getting to enhance
her kicks with the love love fruit she
is a real force to be reckoned with and
that's probably why her Bounty is 1
billion 659 million in terms of hockey
boa has access to Observation Armament
and conqueror saki although we rarely
see her using any of these finally boa
can be pretty deceptive and cunning
unless Luffy is around when he is she
turns into a complete doting dummy now
let's talk about s snake obviously she
is a younger looking boa with all the
normal seraphim bonuses but I am curious
as to how the devil fruit will be
implemented I'm hoping they don't go
with the it works the same way look at
this child and Turn to Stone because
that could be awkward but there are two
ways I could see it working firstly
isolate the ability that turns people to
Stone I don't see this happening as most
of the artificial devil fruits seem to
be weakened not enhanced versions of the
original so if we're going to keep it I
would like to go with the second option
where we play it off as a gag we have
this seraphim who is totally confident
in her powers and trying to turn people
to Stone and they're just like I think
I'm gonna pass actually and that could
be a bit of a fun bit of course we don't
know if she'll even have the same devil
fruit or if it will be replaced with
something else but time will tell next
up we have crocodile while not having
any animal features himself like boa
it's made up for by his pets crocodile
has an entire collection of banana wani
basically giant crocodiles yes they're
crocodiles I know the dub calls them
banana Gators but look at their teeth
those are some giant crocodiles and they
have bananas growing out of their head
now it could also be argued that the
scar across crocodile's face is meant to
look like a crocodile's mouth but
personally I'm not big on that idea
crocodile himself looks more like a mob
boss fitted with a giant poisonous
pirate hook and that's pretty fitting
considering he ran an underground pirate
crime syndicate called brokeworks his
original goal in the series was to use
his immunity as a warlord to go
unimpeded as he took over alabasta to do
this he would use rain powder and his
devil fruit to bring a several year-long
drought to the country and place the
blame on King Cobra as he positioned
himself to be a hero in the people's
eyes all of this to gain access to the
Royal tomb where he could use Nico Robin
to read the poneoglyphs and locate the
ancient weapon pluton a ship so powerful
it could obliterate an entire Island and
effectively make him the king of the
world and that is kind of crocodile in a
nutshell he is manipulative he's willing
to ruin other people's lives to get
ahead but most of all he is organized
and looks at the big picture often
relying on others to do the dirty work
so that he can remain in the clear that
said he is also very prideful and very
much an opportunist for example even
though he hates Luffy he's willing to
work with him to escape impel down even
if he needs a bit of coaxing from Eva
who seems to have some dirt on him that
he doesn't want to be made public
something to note about crocodile is
that while he can be a bit of a bastard
it is also undeniable that his
underlings are completely loyal towards
him with the best example being Daz
bones who would just about die for
crocodile if he wanted him to this being
incredibly relevant as he and mihawk
came together with buggy to create the
cross Guild the house has seemingly no
experience with any sizable crew and
buggy is buggy so crocodile with his
excellent sense of organization and
Leadership is monumentally important for
this group between the three of them
mihawk seems to bring some legitimacy
and power buggy since spring enthusiasm
and his cult of personality and
crocodile keeps things running
efficiently but let's talk devil fruit
because his is a doozy being the only
logia among the original Seven Warlords
crocodile has the Sunnah tsuna Nomi or
the Sansan fruit this allows him to turn
his body into sand and makes him
impervious to any attacks that don't
include hockey that said he is extra
weak to water as any liquids will
solidify him and make him vulnerable to
attacks at the same time though anything
he touches with his right hand can be
completely dehydrated and shriveled
including any water that would touch him
so while water does counteract him more
than others he also is a counter for
water itself it's kind of a who hits who
first situation with his fruit crocodile
can produce and manipulate sand however
he would like he can create dust devils
or sandstorms turn the lower part of his
body into sand and Propel himself
forward similar to flight and he can
even make things like plants people
animals or even inorganic material like
buildings completely turned to dust
crocodile has a lot more going for him
than most of the other Warlords but most
importantly he's just very well-rounded
and effective at everything he does is
smart confident powerful charismatic and
his devil fruit is insane and speaking
of which it's one that as seraphim would
be mind-blowingly powerful if it had
this is pretty interesting though
especially because we've seen a logia
being integrated with other pacifistas
with the Pika pikanomi so we aren't
really sure if logia can be introduced
in the same way as other fruits so we'll
have to see how that actually plays out
in integrating that fruit with the new
seraphim I'd say that at a base it would
be able to create and manipulate sand
while also dehydrating things I'm not
sure if it would be able to turn itself
in the sand like a normal Loki it does
though next up the warlord with one of
the coolest devil fruits and the most
useless personality Gekko Moria his name
is based on a pun where tokage means
lizard in Japanese and kage means Shadow
so the dark and gloomy dude gets the
name lizard that said in terms of design
he's obviously a lot more like a bat but
I guess we're not going with that Moria
comes in just a little bit taller than
Kuma and his body is almost completely
opposite wakuma looks incredibly
top-heavy like a dude who's never worked
out his legs in his life Moria instead
looks like a bowling pin and I gotta say
of all the Warlords Moria is probably
tied for my least favorite he's just
kind of really super lame to me but let
me know if you agree in the comments
Maria had a bounty of 320 million when
he led the Gekko Pirates against the
Beast pirates in one mono 20 years ago
in this battle moria's entire crew was
killed leaving him with nothing so
instead he looked towards creating an
undead crew that could rival kaido
before leaving wano he would pillage
ryuma's grave stealing his body and the
shisui and then would return to the West
Blue where he constructed Thriller bark
and joined Warlords from here he would
have people like Absalom perona and Dr
Hogback joined his crew and together
they would create and Lead his zombie
island with the power of His devil fruit
moriat would set up Thriller bark in the
Florian triangle to prey on Lost ships
abducting their crew and stealing their
Shadows to create more zombies
eventually he would find brook and five
years after that the straw hats would
arrive and put a stop to him recently we
saw him attacking hachinosu Island and
Blackbeard however we have yet to learn
what happened in this incident other
than finding out that Absalom was killed
and that Blackbeard ended up inviting
morya to join his crew while Moria is a
bit of a dud his devil fruit most
certainly isn't
or shadow shadow fruit enables morya to
steal the shadows of other people and
insert them into other bodies if he
places them into a living body that
person becomes more powerful if he
places them into a dead body he can
create a zombie that he has complete
control over in the event the shadow
belongs to someone with significant
willpower they might not be under his
control immediately but over time they
will quickly begin to listen to him
there doesn't seem to be a limit to how
many zombies morya can control and the
power of the zombie is proportional to
both the Shadows original owner and the
strength of the new body that they find
themselves in which is why Brooke's
shadow in Yuma's body was stronger than
Brooke was so hypothetically morya could
create an infinite and all-powerful army
if he got his hands on enough people for
those whose Shadows have been stolen
they will fall into a two-day long coma
and then must stay out of direct
sunlight or they will burst into ashes
and die and once they die the zombie
their Shadow is in will also be killed
off the only way to break this curse
without moria's permission is for the
zombie housing their Shadow to consume
salt even without zombies though the
fruit offers some really cool powers for
Moria he can manifest his shadow into a
tangible physical form that can be used
to grab or attack others or to protect
Moria he can produce a nearly
invulnerable Shield or he could make a
Shadow copy of himself that effectively
functions like a logia user being
completely malleable and able to move
however Moria would like him to on top
of that morya can instantly swap places
with this Shadow whenever he wants
making him super difficult to pin down
that said morya has no mention of hockey
which is so pathetic finally Moria can
remove the Shadow from his zombies and
consume them to power himself up as we
see with Shadow Asgard the more he
consumes the stronger he gets but also
the more disgusting he looks the
implications this offers in a seraphim
probably being called sbat are pretty
obvious be being able to create an army
to multiply their own strength or to
create a shadow double is just
ridiculous it means that along with the
army of seraphim you'll also have to
contest with an army of zombies and as
the seraphim seem much stronger than
morya they could definitely collect
Shadows belonging to much stronger
people next up we have someone with a
fairly similar power in some regards to
morya's doflamingo with his feather boa
styled after a flamingo is probably the
most just straight up evil of the
original Warlords originally he was a
Celestial Dragon however his father
homing decided that he wanted to live
among the common people the people
though in his new town rejected the Don
Quixote family burning down their
mansion attacking them and forcing them
to live in a small shed and eat from
garbage in retribution for the evils
enacted by the other world Nobles Dopey
hated his father for making this choice
and even more so when the living
conditions caused his mother to fall ill
and pass away however the breaking Point
came when the villagers got together
lynched the remaining family members
stringing them high up on a wall above
flames and berated them and shot at them
here joffe would awaken his conquerors
hockey and declare that he would burn
the whole world to the ground soon after
he would be found by treble and start
the doflamingo family this would go
pretty well for him until his brother
rosenante would betray him acting as a
double agent for sengoku leading Dopey
to trust very few people and becoming an
even more angry person Duffy would try
to get the ope ope Nomi so that he could
have someone perform the immortality
surgery on him however rosinante instead
gave this to law and then hid him away
so that he could not be found over the
following years Dopey would gain a
bounty of 340 million berries before
being picked up by the world government
to act as a warlord and like crocodile
he would use this immunity to conquer a
nation he chose drastrosa using his
devil fruit to cause the king to attack
his people then presenting himself as a
hero who would step in to save that only
to become their next Mad King this would
last until Luffy and the straw hats
showed up and freed the nation from him
that said dophi is one of the most
important characters in the series as he
seems to be informed about some of the
secrets of the world he knows about the
immortality surgery he knows about the
secret treasure of marijua and he talks
about an upcoming War for the empty
Throne it seems like many of the
unanswered questions that the audience
still has Dopey has the answers to so
let's talk devil fruit Dopey has the Ito
etonomi or the string string fruit this
allows him to create and manipulate
strings that are incredibly durable and
super sharp it's a very versatile
ability and offers a lot more than you
might think for example Dopey can attach
these strings to clouds and use them to
swing from like Spider-Man meaning he
can essentially fly as long as it isn't
too clear of a day then we have dopey's
go-to ability Parasite by attaching
strings to people he can control every
movement they make he can make string
clones a giant shrinking bird cage that
slices through everything in his path he
could slashed through things with his
strings raise their temperature to melt
through things shoot strings like
bullets and like a million other things
and that's before Awakening where he
turns everything around him into Strings
as well that he can control Dopey is
basically evil Spider-Man on crack and
that's before we even get to his hockey
having conquerors hockey strong enough
to knock out the majority of G5 Marines
in Punk Hazard Armament hockey that is
top tier allowing him to cut smoker
resist Luffy's jet Gatling and send
Luffy flying with a punch as well as
being strong enough to resist laws
slicing abilities inside of room and
also having observation hockey although
it's unclear to what level the dude is
crazy strong crazy versatile and it's
obvious why he was able to push Luffy to
as much of his limits as he did much
like moria's seraphim a doflamingo
seraphim model would be crazy having
access to all of these string string
fruit abilities would make that model an
absolute threat but it's what happens
when paired with the other seraphin
models that makes it a very terrifying
ability this is kind of where the combos
begin to come into play because together
the Warlords can do some insane stuff
imagine in a situation where we have S
Bear s snake s bat and S Flamingo names
pending bear launches snake into a group
where she uses her devil fruit to turn
people into stone then you have bat and
Flamingo walk in to steal their shadows
and put parasites on them meaning we can
create a zombie that's just as strong as
they are while also controlling their
main body and all of this can happen
within a matter of seconds and in the
background I don't know you have S
sharks swimming through the ground and
cheering them on or something we've seen
the warlord's fruits in isolation but as
a team their possibilities and combos
are kind of endless that said though
that wraps up the original Seven so
let's talk about their Replacements Jim
they resigned and crocodile doflamingo
and Moria would all have their warlord
ships reversed the first replacement
would be Blackbeard Marshall D teach
Blackbeard remains to be one of the most
interesting Mysteries remaining in the
one-piece World in our theories on just
about every aspect of his character from
its Origins and being tied to rocks to
zedek to his weird body which allowed
him to eat two devil fruits and that
doesn't require sleep and of course we
have him being referred to as a they by
Luffy and Zorro and not in the typical
pronoun sense but instead seeming to
imply they are multiple people there's
just so many unanswered threads about
him and it's hard not to be interested
as he might assume by his name
Blackbeard is based on the real-life
Blackbeard Edward Teach interestingly
though the real Blackbeard seems to have
had his identity divided among three
different characters on whitebeard's
crew with his first name Edward being
given to Edward Newgate Whitebeard teach
being given to Marshall D teach and
thatch the alternative spelling of his
name being given to the person that
Blackbeard would need to kill to get the
dark dark fruit and yes I know
whitebeard's last name is in reference
to the prison I was just talking about
his first thing aside from his name
though teach at least in his post-time
skip section of the story looks much
more like the real Blackbeard although
much bigger much sturdier somehow and
much grosser we know that as a child
teach was picked up by the Whitebeard
Pirates and over the years he would be
offered the role of division Commander
however he would turn this down to keep
attention off of himself he was instead
trying to buy time until the dark dark
fruit appeared and when it did he would
kill thatch to steal the fruit and leave
the white-beard Pirates while creating
his own crew of course sometime before
leaving the Whitebeard Pirates he would
come across Shanks and their battle
would leave a scar across shanks's eye
as well as giving Shanks a powerful
sense of concern towards Blackbeard we
don't know exactly when this happened
but we know Shane Banks already had his
scar when he was staying in fuchsia so
it was a while back anyways after
crocodile is removed from the Warlords
teach sends Lafitte to the world
government to get him the title of
warlord despite not having a bounty at
this point which is very interesting
considering he had been a pirate on one
of the most renowned Crews for several
decades as a warlord he would capture
Ace and give him to the world government
so that he could be executed and thus
triggering marineford however while
everyone was busy preparing for that war
he broke into impel down reaching level
6 and forcing the criminals at that Lair
to fight to the death whoever survived
would be picked up for his crew along
with the previous head Jailer of impel
down shiryu from here he would wait
until the Battle of marine Ford was
approaching its end and everyone was
exhausted then arriving with his new
buffed up crew to seize the opportunity
to take on Whitebeard kill him and steal
his devil fruit making Blackbeard the
only character in series with two fruit
both of which are insanely broken from
here he would enter the new world and
become a yonko he sets up base of
operations in hachinosu Island then
going on to steal some of the most
powerful devil fruits that he could find
in order to create the ultimate devil
fruit empowered crew and that kind of
brings us up to where we're at right now
with his final Bounty resting at 3
billion
996 million Blackbeard of course has
access to Armament hockey powerful
enough to stop a sword Slash from s hock
on Amazon Lily a slash that cut an
entire mountain in half an observation
hockey that allows him to tell how
powerful other people are we often see
him gauging how strong Luffy is with
just a glance that said we still haven't
seen conquerors hockey on him but let's
be real he probably has it of course we
do know that he has two devil fruits
firstly the dark dark fruit a unique
logia that turns the user Into Darkness
however it does not make them intangible
to damage like every other ogia does but
instead actually makes them feel more
pain than they normally would with this
fruit Blackbeard is able to pull
anything into his darkness and on a
larger scale he can absorb things like
fire weapons people or entire towns
which can be released whenever he would
like them to be he also has some control
over gravity to some extent being able
to pull people towards him from a
distance most importantly though anyone
he touches will have their devil fruit
abilities negated while they're in
contact which is a huge game changer
it's implied that this fruit might also
be tied to Blackbeard's ability to steal
other devil fruits but we still don't
have enough information on that and then
there's the fruit that he's stole from
Whitebeard the Quake Quake fruit
allowing him to create vibrations and
shock waves that can travel through any
medium ground water or even air these
are strong enough to shake or rip apart
the entire Island and it said that the
fruit has the ability to destroy the
entire world when he first gets it he
does have some difficulty controlling in
this ability by limiting its destructive
force but by the time the time skip
rolls around it's safe to say he's
mastered or at least improved his skill
with it that said we haven't seen too
many moments of him using this fruit
outside of just slamming it for the
biggest impact that he can make now
here's the big question
will there be a Blackbeard seraphim and
this question is relevant for all of the
replacement Warlords because between
Blackbeard and law the devil fruits that
they have are just ridiculous a seraphin
model with Blackbeard's fruits could
absorb anything destroy anything and
turn off anyone's devil fruit of all the
seraphim this is the one that would have
the most potential for eliminating any
enemy they came across which is why it
really matters if the world government
is making this model or not and speaking
of law let's get into him next named
after the battles in which Napoleon lost
in those being Trafalgar and Waterloo
and being converted to Trafalgar D water
law he was born in the country of
flevance in the north blue and lived in
White City his parents were doctors who
trained him and his sister in the craft
however the town had been poisoned by
Amber LED and everyone there would die
before reaching adulthood apparently the
world government knew about this Amber
LED situation and just didn't tell the
public which is not very cash money
instead they put the city into
quarantine and law would only survive
because he snuck out hidden under a pile
of corpses eventually finding its way to
doflamingo's crew here cortisone would
take him under his wing and tell him
that the d-clan were the natural enemies
of God as well as Force feeding him the
abeape Nomi and sacrificing himself to
save law lot would go on to form the
heart Pirates named after Corazon which
means heart in Spanish and would earn
enough Renown to be labeled one of these
supernovas it would take part in Marine
Ford sort of as he saved Luffy and
during the time skip he would be
responsible for the rocky Port incident
then bringing the hearts of 100 pirates
of the world government and earning the
status of warlord finally he would
create an alliance with the straw hats
to take down doflamingo kaido and big
mom earning his new Bounty of 3 billion
when it comes to his devil fruit law has
a big one the ape allows law to create a
spherical operating room in which he is
basically a God he can freely manipulate
anything within that room rearrange body
parts swap the locations of two items
and do really whatever he wants he can
cut people in half without injuring them
or make Precision Cuts with radio knife
or even swap people's personalities into
a new body the possibilities really are
endless with this fruit we even see him
Awakening this fruit on guano as he
fights big mom and it drastically
increases the amount of damage he can do
especially with things like puncture
surge basically he's hella versatile and
super strong but the most important
thing he can do is the immortality
surgery however the previous user of the
fruit apparently was gave their life to
make someone else Immortal or something
along those lines it's kind of vague
when Dopey explains it but again we have
some interesting questions when it comes
to the seraphim
can the world government artificially
create this fruit could a seraphim
sacrifice themselves to make someone
else Immortal could they make more than
one of this fruit and produce an
infinite Army of immortal world
government employees there is a lot of
implications based on what the answers
to these questions are moving on to
Buggy the clown ducky has continued to
fail upwards through his entire life and
it's kind of amazing starting as a crew
member of the Roger Pirates along with
Shanks but as the crew was dissolved he
chose to forge his own path rather than
becoming a member of shanks's crew and
you could say that they both did equally
well as Shanks became a yonco pretty
quickly and by the start of the story
buggy had wrapped up a bounty of 15
million ah well he did his best
buggy was kind of a gag character but
his crew was surprisingly passionate
about him and extremely loyal and this
kind of continues through the entirety
of the story his greatest skill is his
Charisma and his ability to Bluff rather
than anything relevant on the
battlefield buggy would be captured by
the Marines and brought to impel down
where he partners with Luffy to escape
and free a ton of prisoners who would
become fully loyal towards him he was
just kind of in the right place at the
right time and at Marine Ford everyone
sees him at a stage where he had just
escaped from impel down it's revealed
that he was on Roger's crew and he at
least to others seems to talk to
Whitebeard like that are in equal and
suddenly there's this weird Mythos and
Legend around his character to everyone
else he's suddenly a pirate of pedigree
who had done the impossible and stood on
equal footing with the World's Strongest
Man add in that he already has a cult
following and buggy finds himself self
to become a force of nature a cult of
personality the world government offers
him the position of warlord as the
following that he had established could
be seen as a threat and that's kind of
where things sat for a bit that is until
the dissolution of the Warlords when the
world government began hunting them
buggy joins together with mihawk and
crocodile to form cross Guild offering
bounties instead on Marines in
retribution for them hunting the
Warlords however buggy again would be
given credit for this and was now seen
as someone who had both crocodile and
mihawk two legends in their own right
working under him his Legend grew as the
result and as did his following and
because of the string of being in the
right place at the right time he's given
the title of yonko and a bounty of 3
billion 189 million which is wild
Buggy's devil fruit while not anything
crazy isn't really terrible either he
has The Chop Shop fruit a devil fruit
allowing him to bisect his body at any
point point and make those separated
Parts move in any way that he wants as
long as they're within a range
furthermore as long as his feet are on
the ground or being carried the rest of
him can fly and finally this also makes
him immune to being cut or sliced in a
similar way to Luffy being immune to
blunt force damage it has about the same
creative range as base form Luffy and
the gum gum fruit in the chop chop fruit
kind of parallel each other in a lot of
ways however like I said buggy isn't
about battle prowess it's much more
about how people see him if he had a
seraphim I mean meh it could bisect
itself but I don't really think it would
be as useful as the other ones unless it
was specifically hunting down Swordsmen
like Zorro or mihawk and finally our
last warlord is Edward Weevil the
supposed son of Whitebeard and my other
least favorite warlord along with Moria
we don't have a ton about this dude at
some point it seems like he was just
kind of introduced just to be forgotten
Weevil looks like a big round Viking who
doesn't seem to quite all be there
definitely more Brawn than brain
apparently he joined the Warlords during
the time Skip and his hobbies include
hunting down the Whitebeard pirates and
their allies while Weevil isn't about
that whole thinking thing he does allow
his mother to tell him what to do and
freely control him basically all there
is to this guy is that he's strong he
believes he's the heir to whitebeard's
Legacy that whitebeard's crew is
unworthy and that he hates Blackbeard
for killing his supposed father he had a
crude a bounty of 480 million before
becoming a warlord and after becoming a
warlord he continued to cause
catastrophes such as killing over 600
civilians Weevil has not been shown to
use a devil fruit yet but instead seems
to use a naginata like Whitebeard did
along with Armament and observation
hockey if all the seraphim do end up
getting a devil fruit I'd imagine the
Blackbeard one will get the darkness
fruit while weevils would get the Quake
Quake fruit though I'm sure there'd be
several other options that would work as
well I wish there was more to say about
Weevil but there just isn't at this time
so maybe we'll get more information in
the future
now finally I do want to mention one
thing that could be super interesting
while he never became a warlord
gets the ace was offered the position of
warlord and I doubt we'll see it but a
seraphim modeled after Ace could be a
phenomenal storytelling device
especially if he had to battle against
either Sabo or Luffy in the future and
that's where we're gonna end it covering
all 11 of the seven Warlords of the sea
with a bonus mention for Ace I think
looking to these guys offers a really
interesting perspective on what might be
to come but even if it doesn't there's
just some of the most interesting and
unique characters in the series in this
group and out of all of them I think my
personal favorites would probably be
mihawk and law but really they're all
very cool except Moria and Weevil let me
know who your favorites are in the
comments down below and let me know if
you hate those two as much as I do also
you can tell us if you think that we'll
see seraphim modeled after the
replacement Warlords and what do you
think of the idea of an ace seraphim
with all that said though we are going
to end it there if you enjoyed the video
remember to leave a like and if you're
new to the channel remember to subscribe
for more one piece content in the future
or if you're looking to support me
directly you can head over to my channel
axelbeats where I have a series on
analyzing villains and I've talked about
a lot of one piece and my hero Academia
characters over there so you might enjoy
it that's all for now though until next
time I hope you all remember to stay
excellent